since the 2008 financial crisis the S&P
500 has beaten the average returns for
hedge funds every single year until 2018
and even in 2018 hedge funds only beat
the S&P 500 by a quarter percent while
the S&P 500 has been destroyed hedge
funds all the other years evidently the
large fees making hedge fund managers
which are making investors poor but
despite all of this rich people continue
to invest in hedge funds so why do rich
people love hedge funds
[Applause]
well the thing is all of these
statistics are misleading because they
use average instead of the median one of
the basic rules of forming statistics is
using the median whenever a sample is
heavily skewed towards one side like
hedge funds the thing is the top ten
hedge funds by size control 566 billion
dollars out of the total three point two
trillion dollars under management by
hedge funds considering that there are
more than 10,000 hedge funds this means
that the top point one percent of hedge
funds by size control more than a six of
all funds under management by hedge
funds as a result if they do good they
have a huge positive impact on average
hedge fund returns and vice versa so
just because the average hedge fund
return is lower than the S&P 500 it
doesn't mean the average hedge fund
underperforms S&P 500 to get an accurate
view of how the average hedge fund
performs we would have to look at the
median return of all hedge funds instead
the average unfortunately this is not
available so we can't tell if the
average hedge fund outperforms a market
or not but I think we'd all agree that
rich people will be putting their money
where they make the most amount of money
and this tends to be smaller hedge funds
generally worth well under twenty five
billion dollars there's no concrete
evidence that bigger funds do worse but
that has been the general correlation
even Warren Buffett one of the best
investors of all time has been having
trouble being the S&P 500 the past few
years as his funds have grown larger and
larger of course value investing like he
does and hedge fund investing are not
the same but this shows how having too
much money actually makes it harder to
invest all of it effectively considering
this who is contributing to these large
hedge funds that have consistently been
underperforming the market well the
answer is you indirectly the vast
majority of investors in these large
hedge funds are not rich individuals but
rather institutions like banks and
pension funds these institutions have
diversification requirements that forced
them to place a percentage of their own
Spence into professionally managed hedge
funds like Bridgewater associates or to
Sigma these large institutions aren't
allowed to hand over billions of dollars
to single managers as they would be seen
as too risky so they're forced to hand
over a certain percentage to big funds
despite their performance but this is
precisely where the rich have been
investing since the financial crisis
taking a look at this graph you can see
that direct allocations to single
managers have been on the rise since
2008 while funds held by hedge fund
companies have been declining as
institutions are forced to contribute to
hedge fund companies these funds
continue to grow despite bad performance
leaving us to wonder what idiots are
investing here the thing is we all
realize that's actually ourselves
meanwhile British people who do invest
in hedge funds flock towards single
managers or smaller hedge funds and thus
based our strategy rather than the
prestige size or background of the fund
and clearly this is very lucrative if
you invest in the right managers taking
a look at the top hedge fund managers
buy returns and consistency you can see
that they make much more than the S&P
8% return or 10% with Devens reinvested
or whatever the exact number is actually
quite irrelevant because these guys blow
the sp500 after water making 30 to 40
percent returns year after year of
course these funds aren't getting these
numbers every single year but there are
plenty of hedge funds that have been
consistently outperforming the S&P 500
for example in the ten year period
between 2008 and 2018 the S&P 500 would
have grown your money by one hundred
fifty six percent or about two and a
half times your money so if you started
with $100,000 you would have $250,000 in
2018 with John Hancock you would have
had three hundred and seventy three
thousand dollars with Naveen you would
have had three hundred ninety three
thousand dollars and with PIMCO you
would have had four hundred and eleven
thousand dollars as you can see plenty
of hedge funds beat the S&P 500 now that
doesn't mean that hedge funds are the
best option though funds you invest in
hedge funds require constant monitoring
and
management to ensure you were
continuously beating out the market the
S&P 500 is still one of the best options
if you want to just keep contributing
mindlessly and still enjoy great returns
in fact Warren Buffett has told his
trustee in charge of his estate to
invest 90% of sports into the sp500
after he dies this just goes to show how
reliable and safe the sp500 is but at
the same time that's why many savvy rich
investors love hedge funds and continue
to contribute to them sadistic s-- will
often tell you the hedge funds are poor
investments but that's heavily because
of large hedge funds that dominate the
market using money from institutional
investors in reality many hedge funds
can be very good investments
significantly outperforming the market
of course as funds have their own set of
cons and risks but don't discredit hedge
funds altogether just because you see
such statistics which investors continue
to grow their wealth every day using
such a funds you just have to choose the
right one make sure to subscribe to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]